poverty is visible on every corner of
this neighborhood of Tripoli the impacts
of Lebanon's worst economic crisis in
decades is felt the most here we spoke
to people from different communities
that fought bitterly over sectarian
divisions only just a few years ago now
they stand side-by-side in protest
against the government this man tells us
the ceilings of houses are crumbling and
buildings are unsafe every family here
is suffering one way or another his
elderly neighbor shouts from his balcony
that he has nothing to his name in
another part of Tripoli Ruggie has just
a few cents left his last meal was a
loaf of bread shared with his family of
three he says they have nothing to eat
this woman tells me she lost four
children in the civil war she too can
barely make ends meet she's not the only
one we've only been here for a few hours
and we're already hearing all sorts of
stories of poverty and we've actually
been stopped a number of times by people
that are wanting to show us the harsh
conditions that they're living in as you
can see just behind me there now there's
no jobs no medication and not even food
for some and they're asking the same
questions over and over again where are
the politicians and why is the
government not helping them the new
government says fixing the economy is a
priority the World Bank has warned that
poverty will rise by a further 50% if
the financial crisis continues many
families are relying entirely on charity
bholaram
we're serving society as much as we can
but the absence of the government is
having a huge effect we're seeing it and
this economic crisis is bigger than any
of us frustrated and desperate this
father and son tell us they too are
struggling I'm at home without a job
what can I do I'm forced to protest why
should I trust this new government when
even the international community is
cautious unemployment in true
has reached nearly 60% many children
aren't attending schools and with an
influx of hundreds of thousands of
Syrian and Palestinian refugees the
newly elected mayor of Tripoli says his
city is at breaking point inaudible a
deeper bond man we're trying our best to
help people as much as we can but we're
limited by the government as a
municipality I have to get any decision
approved first by the interior ministry
before we can implement anything with
not much left to lose people here are
keeping the anti-government movement
alive they say they feel neglected and
they're demanding change
so to hide out al jazeera Tripoli